-Now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
decoration disasters
from you guys.
This first one is from
@ashawnishing.
-Ashawnishing.
-Ashawnashin.
[ Laughter ]
I can smell the whiskey
from here.
Is everything okay?
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @ashawnishing.
He says...
-Yeah!
[ Laughter ]
That's using the old noggin.
That's using the heart.
-This one's from @AlexKaseberg.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from
@ArtisticFlair04.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Gary.
-"Oh, I like it."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @uhlollygagger.
-Uh, lollygagger?
-U-H Lollygagger.
-What is it?
Uh...lollygagger?
-"Uh, what is lollygagger?"
[ Laughter ]
She says...
Look at the photo.
Look at the picture.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
That is frightening.
-[ Laughing ]
-"I will eat you."
-Devil on the Shelf.
This one's from @Kimis52369.
She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
This one's from @jgarner5.
She says...
Here's a photo.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Ho, ho, ho.
This one's from @dallasmavs33.
She says...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hanukkah bush.
This one's from @sdeckerville.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Oops.
-Mm. Sounds like someone
was snooping for presents.
-Yeah.
-[ Laughing ]
This one is from @mmmcinto.
She says...
Take a look.
Not bad.
-Aww.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-"I can't reach!"
"Get the hookers."
[ Laughter ]
"We're here to help you kids."
-"Get the eggnog,
and get the hookers."
[ Laughter ]
-"Put a little eggnog
in this scotch."
[ Laughter ]
This one's from @TrinaScaglione.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Come on.
Why?
-Gosh.
Why'd you do that, Grammy?
-Oh, this is interesting.
It's from @erinl.
And she said...
Look at what she did.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Yeah.
Mom for the win.
-Come on, Mom!
-Mom for the win.
This last one's from
@MonikaHomes.
She said...
There you go.
Those are our
"Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.